Candice Owens is saying a lot about it
has for a long time she's host of
Candace and we're always happy to have
her on the show tonight Kenneth thanks
so much for coming on so at the same
time that they're you know addressing
these big theoretical macro issues and
changing the American criminal justice
code to be race specific something
that's never been
um they're ignoring the collapse of
daily life for their constituents you
see this everywhere what is it
we don't know what it is it does seem to
be a very strange collision and seeing
her put put this forth is just actually
I'm incredulous and selfishly I'd like
to see it go into a place for maybe just
one day because it would be brilliant
for black conservatives because every
single Democrat would fall by their
sword of course they Reserve their most
hatreds and the most vitriol for black
conservatives people like myself Larry
Elder Clarence Thomas they'd all be
locked up federally trust you if they've
actually gotten put into place uh but I
think it also yields more questions for
me I'm looking at this I'm going what
are they possibly thinking how would
this work what about black on black
criticism were they would they lock me
up for saying something like you know
Sheila Jackson is fundamentally a low IQ
hateful individual I'm just saying that
I don't want to go to prison I'm giving
you a what if scenario if I did say that
would I go to prison and how is this
going to run parallel to their
decriminalization efforts right they
don't want any black and brown people in
prison they want them all to be on the
streets but at the same time they're
saying that they will lock us up and by
the way would this extend to an overseas
policy would I be locked up if I said
anything bad about the late Osama Bin
Laden I mean of course this wasn't well
thought through but because it doesn't
need to be we know that their every
effort is aimed at censoring speech
right the Democrats know that in order
for them to be omnipotent they need to
be able to control words because if they
can control words they can control
thoughts and ultimately what they're
after is brainwash and by the way
they've been really good at brainwash if
speaking of what you just spoke about
you have people that are graduating I
just talked about this today graduating
Harvard who actually believe that men
can be women and women can be men and
all we have to do is change our minds so
they know exactly what they're doing
they know exactly what they're after and
ultimately what they want is full power
and control over every single person and
their households
and they'll use law enforcement to do it
and the police and the FBI and the
courts I wonder if we've laughed too
much at the absurdity of all of this and
not internalized how deadly serious they
are about using power to crush their
political opponents
oh I have been laughing but at the same
time pointing people to the very real
truth and said that what they truly want
is a totalitarian Society they are
following the Playbook you know
everything that they are after they are
attacking religion they are attacking
the First Amendment they continually
want to remove guns from your households
I mean what does that spell out to you
where have we seen this before in every
communist society that exists that has
existed and does exist today because
that is what needs to happen they need
to remove individual power and what's
been very interesting is seeing how
they're breaking down people's mentality
right we are becoming a fundamentally
weak country you have people that cry at
the drop of a hat because they've been
misgendered of course they know that
that these people are not going to be
able to take them on in the future
because people are going to stand up to
government when they can't even stand up
to themselves and look themselves in the
mirror and say no actually I cannot be
this person I can't just wake up and be
say that I'm a man or I'm a woman so
it's it's it's so Machiavellian and it's
so important that we keep talking about
it you can laugh to stay safe to stay
sane but also recognize that something
very real is happening in this country
and it's day dangerous and it's Sinister
it could not have happened five years
ago that's exactly right I couldn't
agree more kennestone's great to see you
tonight thank you very much
thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight